robert spencer joe biden said recently
that the alliance between
israel and the united states is as close
as ever
and he tried to be as supportive as
trump was at least verbally
and yet biden is apparently surrendering
to all iranian demands regarding the new
jcpoa what will america
do if israel is forced to attack and
destroy iranian nuclear sites
on their own to save themselves
i wouldn't be in the least surprised if
america intervened to prevent israel
from doing that
is a big new brzezinski called upon
obama to
actually use american uh planes
to intercept israeli planes going to
bomb iran
if israel had gone to do that in 2012
and the biden administration
is so full of opponents of israel
i would be surprised if that kind of
recommendation did not come up again
because not only is his uh
administration full of haters of israel
but there is no counterbalance there are
no supporters of israel
among his the biden team and
consequently
there's only one voice that's going to
be heard and
it's the anti-israel voice the united
states cannot be counted upon by israel
at this point as a reliable ally
and has to act accordingly
you